here I am in a new file and we are
expanding our products to create better
customer experience so I want to add
easy product filtering I am just writing
a comment in natural language and click
on the duet AI magic wand and duet
generates my product filtering function
I can accept it with a tab this is not
just code generation duet was able to
pull in very specific prod product
related apis and functions and our
methods this is huge typically writing
such code would require very specialized
knowledge now with duet's understanding
of my company's SDK and code base I can
save time resourcing training hours all
without compromising quality that is
huge